[Music]
well it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirror
columnist susie boniface and the
telegraph columnist madeleine grant
lovely to see you both thank you much
very much for joining us this new year's
evening let's see what's on the front of
some of those papers the daily mail
quotes the health secretary sajid javed
pledging he'll do everything in his
power to ensure that there isn't another
covered lockdown in 2022 unless it's as
a last resort
the telegraph leads with the new year's
honors just announced and the damehood
for dr jenny harris the head of what the
paper describes as the chaos hit covert
test and trace system
the express says that she chris whittie
and jonathan van tam who are all honored
are the real heroes of the pandemic
whilst the star reports on that news
that james bond actor daniel craig is
also included in the awards
the guardian claims an exclusive report
on what it calls the appalling scale of
abuse and threats directed at the
government's team of pandemic advisors
and the yorkshire post reveals that 152
million pounds has already been spent
preparing the eastern section of the hs2
rail link which has now been halted it
says the bill to the taxpayer could go
even higher
so let's turn to susie boniface and
madeleine grant welcome to you both
lovely to see you both this evening um
and a lot of your choices this evening
are around the new year's honors lists
um let's start with the telegraph uh and
you susie and this is arizo tony tony
blair is knighted
14 years after departing number 10 do
you think that is uh this is the right
award to give him and is this the right
time
well most prime ministers do get
knighted uh apart from theresa may of
course whose husband had to be knighted
in order for her to be a lady because
that's the way our ridiculous system
works
um and uh baroness thatcher of course is
made of baroness um but tony blair has
waited quite a long time 14 years uh
john major waited eight years uh other
premieres have been knighted rather
quicker and there was speculation
perhaps slightly fed by some people at
the palace some courtiers who said that
there was some
wish to keep him waiting as it were
because of the way that the the death in
1997 of diana princess of wales was
handled the whole people's princess
business the whole
you know the queen having to come down
from balmoral uh the pressure that
downing street we know did put on
buckingham palace to do things
differently
when the queen and the royal family
wanted to protect william and harry
moore and the the government wanted the
monarch to be front and center and
leading the country and and representing
what's going on so he's waited a long
time uh he's going to be made a night uh
companion of the garcia i think most
noble order of the garter um which is a
super dead posh one a super dead posh
knight if you can get a posh knight and
that's in the personal gift of the queen
so she has had to be um persuaded that
it's time to give him one but obviously
2021 is time for everyone to move on it
would appear and he's finally got what
he wants
one assumes he must want because he's
certainly accepted anyway yes he hasn't
turned it down has he uh and madeleine
obviously a huge number of people to go
through um over the next few minutes and
lots of different ones on different
front pages uh but the express has gone
for honours for our real heroes are
picturing professor chris whittie dr
jenny harris and professor van tam
yes they have and they've also got a
picture of one of my real heroes joanna
lumley um who is it has also been made
today um and it's yes it's
gone for almost all of the top team
involved in the public health decisions
um and you know i think some of some of
this is you know it's a recognition that
at a very difficult time in our in our
country's history um that there has been
a constant source of authority and um
responsibility and i think for some
people having those regular press
conferences was really i don't know i
sort of brought people
soothing to listen to people who are so
clearly at the top of of their game on
the other hand there may be some
controversy with some of these
particularly with um dr jenny harris who
is believed to have got an awful lot
wrong during the pandemic um and i mean
arguably this is an example of how
you know in some ways in this country we
do reward um you know people who've been
proven to be wrong on on big things it's
the kind of the democracy um
as deputy chief medical officer she was
notably wrong on quite a few big issues
you know she was talking down
the importance of testing as a whole and
um talking down the the significance of
ventilation while over emphasizing much
less usually useful interventions like
hand washing and more recently she's
been um
accused of spreading um false data about
the severity of the omicron variant um
so you know i think that on the one hand
we appreciate the tremendous work done
by the public health experts but i think
some of these appointments will prove um
controversial because it seems to be i
guess of a piece with the way in which
um
the
those in in high positions and well
connected are often rewarded um even
when things have gone quite badly for
them when they were involved in those
positions
i mean looking back at the front of the
express um i mean could it be that if
they'd got dame joanna lumley to front
these press conferences would have been
a great deal more calming for all of us
wouldn't it
i certainly think so it's very hard not
to listen to joanna lumley talking about
anything and not feel um reassured but
um i i have to sketch a lot of these
conferences and i i really admire the
way in which um many of them communicate
particularly jonathan van tam and his
his colorful metaphors which i find very
useful as a a bit of a um
a scientific sort of um plebeian um to
hear the things being described in uh
football analogies and trains and other
things that i can actually understand
yeah next slide please have sort of
entered into the national lexicon hasn't
it um susie the telegraph that that also
focuses on on dr jenny harry's as well
doesn't it it's it's dame hood for head
of chaos hit testing system i mean do
you think it's right that she's getting
a damn hood or why is it you think that
she in particular has been singled out
as the one that's a slightly
questionable one
well madeline's right in that she's had
um some controversies i'm sure she and
the others
are all getting their awards because
they have put service to their country
above and beyond everything this year um
and so i'm sure she's done stuff
perfectly well behind the scenes uh and
i think chris whittie should be getting
a knighthood just for the sake of the
idiots he's happy to put up with
grabbing him in the street and so on um
but jenny harry's unfortunately has said
and done a few things very publicly
which have not been uh to anybody's
benefit saying that mosques increase the
risk of infection that there was no need
to do mass testing at the time when we
lost complete track of the
pandemic to start with and there was an
adequate supply of ppe things we don't
we know just aren't true um i'm sure she
justifies it but it does look and i
wouldn't call it the chamocracy i would
call this the establishment rewarding
itself and the people who work for it
and at the same time that we are um you
know remarking upon the people who've
been had an honor this year
there are something like 3 000 men in
this country still surviving from the
atomic tests in the 1950s and 1960s who
are facing 70 years now 70 years next
year in 2022 have been ignored belittled
and ridiculed by the ministry of defense
and successive governments and who've
been refused medals three times in the
last two years
even though they have increased rates of
birth defects in their children their
wives have increased rates of
miscarriage and they have increased
rates of blood cancers the prime
minister promised to meet them in
november and has still not organized
that in fact the ministry of defense is
trying to block it right now as we speak
so there are many many others
nuclear test veterans lollipop ladies
people who are working on the front line
who know that some of the things jenny
harris has said is wrong who easily
deserve huge
honours and recognition and i'm sure
that when we get into the papers
tomorrow and you can see the insides
it's always more fascinating to see
and rewarding to see so the everyday
normal people getting the recognition of
their country that they deserve
um i think those are probably more
important than the ones who make the
front pages most of the time the ones
who make the front pages it's the it's
it's the establishment rewarding itself
there certainly seem to be you know
enormously important to those as you say
that the lollipop men and ladies and the
people uh out there working on the front
line really does seem to uh be
enormously appreciated when they are
honored and
madeline the front of the guardian tell
us a little bit about this story covered
advisors are talking about a tidal wave
of threats and abuse
yes it's a really horrible story this um
the guardian has surveyed a number of
the government scientific and medical
advisors about the scale of um treatment
they've had from the public um the
intimidation and abuse they've
experienced while they've been taking on
these high profile roles and and what
they've come out with is really quite
horrifying um it seems to be every form
of abuse from online attacks to death
threats um and out and out intimidation
um things like photographs of their
homes being shared online um suspicious
packages arriving in the post and i
think perhaps worst of all it's not just
them who are affected but it is spilling
over to their families as well um and
there is um one particularly alarming
example of
where a child of one of these advisors
was targeted by a teacher at their
school um who blamed the child's parents
for um government lockdown policy and i
think it you know it goes back to
susie's point about about the public
service um it's a reminder of the the
great sacrifices that these advisors
have made um even when we you know might
not necessarily agree um with the thrust
of their decisions um that taking on
these high-profile roles is a demanding
task not just because of the the stress
and the enormity of the decisions that
you're having to make and the advice
that you're giving um but also the the
horrible associated abuse and and the
way that can transcend um even to you
know children and members of your family
it's interesting is it susie because a
lot of people in the public eye have had
to put up with abuse on on sites like
twitter for example which i know that
you know a lot about um
and there is this this fit this this now
feeling amongst people that they can say
whatever they like to whoever they like
if they're in the public eye for them to
disagree with them they can say anything
as hateful as they like but this kind of
almost shows it's spilling over into
real life now doesn't it it's
it's almost as if they become emboldened
by being one step removed and now people
are actually
taking the horrible things that they
would maybe say on twitter that you
would maybe think you would never say
that in real life but actually
doing it in real life
yes and i think i mean
madeleine and i and you probably as well
and all the presenters sky will have had
a degree of abuse on on social media
whenever we talk about vaccinations or
the pandemic and would take take some
kind of a line that other people don't
agree with
uh and i i for one am constantly getting
reported to ipso for example to the
press regulator for daring to write
something someone doesn't agree with um
and there's quite often sort of you know
campaigns from accounts with big
followers trying to say you must get rid
of her and stop her doing this danielle
but to a journalist it doesn't matter
too much it's kind of water off a duck's
back most of the time because we're
inured to it right we're trained to it
from a young age when you are a doctor
or a nurse and you're you're giving up
some time to advise the government about
epidemiology
um and pandemics it's not something that
you would expect that your child would
come home from school as madeline said
there and you know be told that a
teacher has blamed you for some kind of
government policy that's going on um
it's not something that the people who
are doing this work
should have to put up with and the
disassociation we have on social media
the fact that we are slightly away from
someone and we don't see their responses
or the way in which they are
making the comment to us
and what we do get is their comments
right up in our face in an intimate
place on our phones on our computers
it's right in our personal space it
hurts more
it's easier to to do it and that has it
does seem to have made some kind of a
change in that people are more prepared
to now as you say to to do it in person
to say things in person that they they
certainly wouldn't have done 10 20 years
ago and i think
part of it as well is
you know um people and commentators
constantly talking about freedom of
speech and getting that mixed up with
the freedom to be bloody rude to people
we don't have that freedom uh we have
freedom of speech but we also have the
responsibility of speaking politely and
civilly to one another and i think
that's something that more people
especially those in the cabinet and the
government and their ruling party should
make a point about well hear hear from
me on that one thank you both very much
for now uh we'll be hearing uh from them
both a lot more after this break and
we're going to be looking at this story
as well as many others hst continues to
haul the government with yorkshire post
saying that the scrapped line could cost
the taxpayer 150 million pounds we'll
look at more detail next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now the daily mirror columnist susie
boniface and the telegraph columnist
madeleine grant thanks again ladies for
joining us we're going to start with the
yorkshire post uh in this half and
madeline perhaps we'll start with you
this hour um
their headline is about the cost of the
scrapping of hs2 we knew that this had
been scrapped this yorkshire leg um but
they're now being able to reveal how
much it's cost so far
in the preparations for it that's been
wasted
yes absolutely it's a as with everything
connected with hs2 it amounts to a vast
money pit um the yorkshire post has done
a freedom of information requests and
they found that hs2 limited has spent
150 million pounds of public money um
buying up land and property along the
eastern leg
to yorkshire which obviously had been
curtailed after the government announced
the cancellation and this is the part
between the midlands and leeds um and it
just seems like the the continually
dithering about that decision
um has not just cost a small fortune but
it's also left vast numbers of people in
a kind of limbo um many homeowners who
thought their properties were going to
be affected have now sold up thinking
that the project was going ahead um and
they've moved quite unnecessarily
i mean i'm not a fan of the project at
the best of times but i think that
whether you're pro or auntie it um the
whole thing's been very badly managed i
mean it's extraordinary how how long
it's all been dragging along and even
now people are still suffering from the
lack of certainty and the kind of
question mark over what is and isn't
going going ahead um
and of course we the taxpayer are
forcing the bill for compensation and so
on i mean all told it seems to have been
a tremendous boon to consultants and
some vastly overpaid hs2 executives
um and a complete waste of time and a
pain for just about everyone else that's
involved with it
and susie if for those who who are keen
on seeing the north and and yorkshire
leveled up uh it's given them a more
gross relative to be the government
hasn't it that this is not in nowhere
going to help leveling up that part of
the world
no of course not it's just a massive
waste of money and they're doing it the
worst possible way as it says in the
story
uh the hs2 leg was originally going to
go through mudrall
outside sheffield which is out of town
area loads of parking great place lots
of connectivity and transport links and
instead they re-routed it
through a housing estate which then had
to be bought up houses are now being
rented everyone lived there who'd bought
those houses out to move out and now
it's not even being used because that
leg's being cancelled and even worse
um because the way the government has
has delayed this leg by not building it
but then saying it's actually going to
have a a review of whether or not it
should build it it is possible to be
living on that route and still have your
home compulsively purchased
uh even though it may not be going ahead
so taxpayers money is still going down
this particular tube even though the
government is has pretty much cancelled
this part of the scheme okay and this is
150 million keep going we have to close
it there cece boniface and madeleine
grant thank you both so much for taking
us through the papers